let's now expand our knowledge of
calculus to the third dimension so
what's what what is it first of all just
what does a function look like in three
dimensions and actually we'll go over
the different types because you can have
a line in three dimensions or kind of a
curve in three dimensions you can have a
surface you could have a vector field
there are different types of
representations we'll see when we start
working with three dimensions but I
think the most intuitive and all none of
these are directly into it and I think
you have to really be able to visualize
them but the most intuitive to me at
least is a surface and three dimensions
and eventually we can expand this into n
dimensions but then it becomes very hard
to visualize so we had our traditional x
and y axes before but now let's let's
give another dimension of height so
let's say that this is my x axis and
I'll draw the positive quadrant that's
my x-axis that's the y-axis and that's
the z axis and the convention is to kind
of follow the right-hand rule where the
x axis cross taking the cross product of
the x axis with the y axis is equal to
the z axis what do I mean by that if
this is X those colors really don't go
well together this is y this is Z what
do I mean by the cross product so if
this is the unit vector in the I in the
X direction so that's I let's say that
this is of length one this is in the Y
direction so it's J of J little cap and
that cap just means it's a unit vector
it in the Y direction but it has a
magnitude of one and I'll do is use a
different color for Z Z is up and the
unit vector for there is K so just and
this is just the convention that I cross
J is equal to K and that's just the
convention you know for drawing the x
axis do we make increasing X pointing
out this way did we make increasing X
point inwards and this gives us the
convention so I as goes in this
direction I'm trying to make sure I can
do my hand properly so let me draw the
cross product so if you take the first
vector put your index finger in the
direction of the first vector
index finger in the direction of the
first vector middle finger in the
direction of the second vector so middle
finger in the direction of second vector
in your other fingers can do what they
need to do so this is going in the
direction of I that is going in the
direction of K sorry of J right in the
y-direction and then you have your palm
of your thumb and then your thumb is
going to open up in this direction your
thumb is going to point up which is the
direction of K so that's just a good to
know where does that convention come
from this is kind of called a
right-handed coordinate system but let's
get to the meat and potatoes so how do
we define a surface in three dimensions
well we can define Z as a function of x
and y so let's do that we could adjust
the notation Z is equal to a function of
x and y and all that means is that if I
give you an x value in a y value get a z
value and so I don't know it'll look you
know ut it'll let me let's pick one Z is
equal to X plus y so let's Z is equal to
I don't know x squared plus y so how do
we plot the points on the surface and
I'll show you actually
computer-generated surfaces surfaces
that are far more professional-looking
than anything I can possibly try to draw
but let's see if we if we were to take
as if so if we said Z is equal so let's
say what's F of f of I don't know 2
comma 2 comma 1 well that would mean X
is 2 so it's 2 squared plus 1 well it
equals 5 and if we have to plot that
point of the surface and maybe I'll
actually graph this one in a little bit
we go along the x axis 2 so 1 2 we go
along the y axis 1 so if we take this
point this is X is equal to Y is equal
to 1 and then we go and then we say well
Z is equal to 5 so we go up here I don't
know
we'd go up five units here and we would
plot that point and you would see if you
kept doing that you would plot a surface
you'd plot a surface and let me clean
this up a little bit so the natural
question that you might want to ask
it'll actually let me show you a surface
I'm afraid that when I manipulate this
graph it'll slow down my computer and
I'll start letting like I'm melting but
I'll take that risk just bear with me so
here is a surface I use using this Java
applet Grapher and it's actually free
I'll give you the link for it but this
surface right here this is I'll actually
show you the graph of this and we'll
start taking the partial derivative
don't worry about this wall well we'll
we'll get to this in a second but this
is a function of x and y you can see
this is the x axis the y axis this the
height is the z axis and i'm this will
probably really slow down my computer
but you can actually rotate it let me do
it look at that I don't want to slow I
don't want to slow things too much down
while I'm trying to do my screen capture
but anyway yeah I think you you would
understand where you pick a an X point
you pick a Y point and then Z this
surface right here without this line
intersecting it this surface right here
is is a function of x and y so the
question is well how do we apply
calculus to surfaces because actually
let me bring that thing on out again
because if you look at the surface if
you were to pick any arbitrary point on
the surface you said what is the slope
of that surface well it kind of has no
meaning because you have to kind of pick
a direction if you said what is the
slope of the tangent line any point on
this graph actually has an infinite
number of tangent lines
I mean think of it this way take a bowl
or something that maybe you know like
this and then take a I don't know a a
toothpick and make that toothpick
tangent to the bowl and you can see that
on any point on the bowl you can just
rotate that toothpick around so you kind
of have to pick the orientation of that
toothpick so what we're going to learn
is when you take a derivative in three
dimensions you have to specify the
direction that you're taking the
derivative in so and this is why I
actually drew
this wall here this wall is the equation
y is equal to 0.3 so you can kind of
view it along this wall y is a constant
right so if we assume that Y is constant
then maybe we could take just the
derivative with respect to X so we would
essentially take the slope of this curve
right here and let's let's figure out
how to do it so first of all what is the
equation of this surface and I I just
picked with the one that they had on
Wikipedia but the equation of that
surface is and I'm gonna remove this now
so I don't sound like I'm melting the
equation of that surface and let me just
clear out everything just because it
probably will probably need the extra
space let me go back to the pen tool
equation is Z is equal to x squared plus
XY plus y squared so we said if we want
to take a derivative it's hard to you
know you can't just say there isn't one
derivative we have to pick a direction
we have to hold everything else constant
and take the derivative with respect to
just one variable and that is called the
partial derivative I know it sounds
fancy but you'll see it's actually no
harder than taking a regular derivative
you just have to make sure you remember
which variable is a variable and which
one is a constant so let's say we wanted
to hold Y constant we just say for any
constant Y how much does Z change with
respect to X then we take the partial
derivative and this is the notation the
partial derivative you could view it as
a D with the top curled the partial
derivative of Z with respect to X it
equals all we do is we take this
expression we take the derivative of X
and we just assume that Y is some
constant so what's the derivative of 2x
with respect to X well it's just 2x
what's the derivative of XY with respect
to X well if Y is just a number is just
a constant remember we're not taking an
implicit derivative here Y is just a
constant so if you have some constant
times X the derivative of that is just
the constant plus y and then what's the
derivative of Y squared squared with
respect to X well we're assuming Y
squared is a constant it's just a number
right y is just an
so the derivative of just a number with
respect to X is just zero so that the
derivative of that is zero so the
partial derivative of Z with respect to
X is 2x plus y now what does that mean
well that means if I were to and let
actually let me give you a little
notation before I show you what that
means another way to write this exact
same thing is if we wrote that f of X f
of X Y is equal to the same thing x
squared plus XY plus y squared
thus it the partial of F with respect to
X we could have written as this
the partial derivative of F with respect
to X and still a function of x and y
right it still depends on what constant
Y are using is equal to 2x plus y anyway
I thought it's it's nice to see that
notation now what does this mean well
what is the slope of Z with respect to X
and say when X is 1 when X is equal to 1
and actually let's pick smaller numbers
when X is equal to I don't know when X
is equal to 0.2 and Y is equal to I
don't know point 2 3 well we could use
this F the partial derivative of F with
respect to X at the point point 2 point
3 is equal to 2 times X that's 0.4 plus
y plus 0.3 so the slope of this function
with respect to X at the point 2 comma
or point 2 comma point 3 is equal to 0.7
let's see if we can visualize that so
that wall represents the line y is equal
to 0.3 and we want the slope at equal at
x is equal to 0.2 so this is X is point
2 right here so the rate at which the
height or the rate at which Z is
changing with respect to X is 0.7 so
every time x increases one Z will
increase by 0.7 so the slope is L is a
little bit less than 1 I think you see
that right thus the tangent right here
is increasing with increasing values of
X but a little bit less than
45 degrees anyway I'm all out of time
see you in the next video